he's really obsessed with american idol
so what he does is like
last week
he was just on the couch just going
through every single contestant system
see if they follow him and then being
like dude i love you you did so great if
you need tips hits you back up and i'm
like bobby what tips are you going to
give him no that's not true it's a lie
and they don't follow him back within
two days he unfollows them back up this
american idol thing yeah i didn't
[ __ ] do that by the way okay
four videos here i'm looking forward all
right stop stop stop for sure i'm sorry
trevor right i want to be we're new
friends right yeah yeah all right so
i love american idol
okay so i admit it there was two dudes
on american idol
that i liked their auditions so what i
did oh you're dming off auditions yeah
i thought you were talking about like
final round
dude but like you're you're like dm and
i'm like welcome to hollywood
noah thompson yes how many followers you
got noah thompson yeah has 7 thousand
followers all right well let's change
the subject